you look amazing thank you what is this
costume well I'm living my best life and
I figured marie-antoinette but now that
I'm here I feel like I'm haunted mansion
like a ballroom dancer from the Haunted
Mansion your first time at this event
right yeah what is this only second this
is only the second year they did it but
I followed last year and I felt very
left out it's like you're a Halloween
queen I am I love all of this so I'm
just I'm really excited
it's a fiance can etc' the ring yes look
at it I love it with it are we wedding
planning right now yes we are
[Music]
we had like a month set you have a month
yeah this year next year next year my
life changed for you guys since becoming
fiance's honestly I just feel really
special because everyone asks about it
and everyone wants to see your ring I'm
like this is what people are talking
about when I yes I feel like a douche
douche bag about this yeah this is my
time are we gonna see the wedding
planning on the next season of van der
Pauw I mean I've been on Vanderpump
rules pretty much like all of my adult
life so anything that's significant in
my life I put out there yeah so I think
it goes without saying you everybody
must have oh what three wedding must
have I don't know yet because this is
the first time I'm doing it I mean
obviously an amazing dress than a second
amazing dress are you gonna change I
think yeah I mean I would be happy to
have like seven dresses I don't need to
enjoy the wedding I can just change the
whole time and then probably just like a
good spray tan derailment music band I'm
leaving that to Beau he's way better
with music than I am
I listen to top 40 so
he's gonna handle that you have to ask
you what is going on with Jax people are
at odds with him they know he loves
unfollowing people on Instagram I'm safe
he hasn't unfollowed me I think he's
kind of scared to like have beef with me
like I feel like oddly safe it's about
you and Kristen you're gonna have to
you're gonna have to watch a lot yeah
[Music]